[Music]
hey guys welcome to my podcast
congratulations
dude it's awesome man you know something
i got it [ __ ]
can't stand wait hold on before we even
start
you guys we appreciate the love on
patreon you guys
the numbers are growing it's a swell of
support we love it
we also love it now if i was a jackass
i would be like you guys smash that like
button
and smash that subscribe button and
smash that bell notification
button i am not a [ __ ] jackass i'm a
real human being
i'm a father and i'm a businessman
wait where is it we got it on the
soundboard dude
the jay-z insecure laughs so what i want
you to do
if if you don't mind
just gently brush up against that
subscribe button
knock a little bit into you know like
you're at a party and
you go to and you and you knock into
something and it breaks a little bit and
you go to fix it and you can't actually
fix it
so you just kind of like leave it a
little bit broken but
you leave the room before it breaks
again do that to the [ __ ]
like button just kind of like oh i can't
oh i can't oh there it is
just place the like button precariously
where it's supposed to be
and then when you see that bell
notification just kind of like do a
a nice little [ __ ] kind of like a
like a swivel on over to the
and then a a touch on the on the bell
notification number i saw somebody
who said on the last video uh last
podcast wow that was the most
comprehensive thing about
like button this and that and [ __ ]
whatever and then somebody said
yeah i've been a subscriber and i'll
also hit the like button on this one
but i'll be damned if i hit that bell
notification and i'm like
wow that's [ __ ] gangster
so yeah subscribe like and [ __ ] dude
it helps it's [ __ ] awesome when you
subscribe and like it if you want to be
a part of this cult you got to subscribe
and like
bell notifications are cool too but if
you're not going to do that subscribe
and like
um the marijuana's got my vision cloudy
tupac laughed like that once and i think
about it a lot it's on the e40 song e40
raps like arnold schwarzenegger
um what the [ __ ] you gotta go for if you
only hesitate
um that's that's e40 slash arnold
schwarzenegger
um a40 arnold
arnold schwartz arnold 40. dumb
uh anyway dude you know what dude some
of the jokes
are gonna hit some of the jokes are
gonna [ __ ] fire on all syllables and
some of the jokes are just gonna lay
flat as [ __ ] man
you know
i feel good though um sometimes i got i
got to be honest
um i start these podcasts and i don't
feel good and sometimes i start the
podcast and i do feel good and i do feel
good now and some days
some days you know when you wake up and
you just feel ugly as [ __ ] you know what
i mean it's just one of those days you
wake up and you're like
uh i'm [ __ ] so ugly dude and you look
in the mirror and you're like yup
you wake up and you're like i hope it's
not an ugly day and then you look in the
makeup and you go
makeup you go look in the mirror
jesus christ man one time for the tumor
um and uh you look in the mirror and
then
you [ __ ] then you're like yep i am
ugly i look like [ __ ]
job of the hutt and then uh some days
you wake up and you're like gonna be a
good day
and you [ __ ] moonwalk on over to the
mirror and you look into it and your
eyes got some sort of sparkle in it man
that was today for me i got a new shirt
that came
put it on oops and [ __ ] ward around
town
i was just you know i had a little step
in my walk
walking around town um you know
pepping my step whatever the [ __ ] they
say and uh
got got a coffee got some food and then
just came back played with the sun dude
god he was in a good mood today he woke
up kristen brought him in and he was
just like da
da da da da da da
i'm like all right i'm up and then you
said mama
he'd come to me and then point to her
mama mama mama
mama and like okay and then he'd see a
ball and he says ba ba
ba he's like a [ __ ] dick tracy
character
like [ __ ] johnny repeats or whatever
the [ __ ]
johnny johnny repeats junior because i'm
johnny
and um but yeah dude and then we were we
were looking at him today
and we we picked up a banana and we and
and we say
and he goes like this
and it was so [ __ ] cute cute dude it
was so cute
because he's only up until this point
done
the same syllable like like butters he
says
my dog he'll my uh my in-cell dog
he'll say buppo or like
bottle is papa but he went ba and then
you saw something
click in his 16 month old brain and he
and it and it just went like change and
he said
but
and it was so [ __ ] cute dude
so by the end of the week if he doesn't
know this song [ __ ] b-a-n-a-n-a-s by
gwen stefani i'm gonna [ __ ] ground
him
that's gonna be the first grounding i'm
gonna do for my son
um yeah so [ __ ] my mans
i don't know i don't know but um you
know i i i i woke up i felt good and
that's good it's good to [ __ ] relish
in those moments
you know because sometimes you don't uh
you don't feel good when you wake up
and um i'll start by saying this man
i have a year's sobriety i have a year
sobriety
uh and i can't believe i'm saying that
and
i i feel good you know and it's hard
um and i don't want to run before i can
walk
um but i'm taking it a day at a time and
i i've been um
[ __ ] man i feel so insecure talking
about this and i feel so
uh exposed to talk about this but i
haven't
uh i haven't had sex with anybody but
uh uh my fiance in the past
year and um i know that's like [ __ ]
whoa what do you deserve a medal
what do you think you get a medal and
the truth is when you're
in [ __ ] uh
sobriety when you're in these meetings
you actually do get a [ __ ] medal
you get one for uh you get one every now
and then and uh you know it's been
coveted and uh
all my stuff's been virtual but um
i don't know man i i never thought i
could do it and i
am doing it and um i just wanted to
share that with you guys and i don't
i don't know i do feel really [ __ ]
insecure opening up talking about it uh
but i do want to
also talk about it so i because i know
other people deal with the same [ __ ]
issue man i mean i've had
i've had a lot of people reach out um
to me since this all went down and and
uh have talked about how they have um
addictions
um whether it be with drugs or sex or
alcohol or whatever it is um and um
i uh i just feel for them man and it's
uh it's it's hard and i never thought i
could do it and i
trust me man if i can do it you can do
it and it's a
you know it gets me [ __ ] emotional
talking about it because um a year
it's been a year and it's just [ __ ] i
never thought i could do it and uh
anyway uh i do feel like i should let
you in on that
since uh i i do want to be transparent
honest with you guys about that
um you know i used
it's weird thinking about my life and
how different it is now um
just i don't know i was in my
my men's group uh yesterday and
we talk about all sorts of issues and
[ __ ] and and i was thinking about
um the the the things that used to like
i used to be the things i used to go to
in my life to make myself
feel adequate you know and it was either
after shows looking for a way to get
laid
or stand up
or at home with my family
and my i mean this was before calvin but
like with
with my um mom and dad or
brother or fiance or whatever it is
um the things that made me
feel adequate
were these things that were on the end
of each spectrum you know you had to
stand up the rockstar lifestyle
and then you had the family stuff and
the middle was was the hardest thing
for me you know like the stand-up
and sex and whatever it was and um
the late nights out that was just
the family stuff was the um
relaxing wow i feel home i feel good
about myself because these people love
me for me and i love them for them i
felt safe
you know but the middle [ __ ] was the
[ __ ] that was
just mind-numbing to me it was
it was like you know when you
here's how here's what i thought it was
before i realized i had a problem
i thought it was i'm a
i'm i'm a comedian and i'm friends with
the most literally the most entertaining
people in the world
um you know i would sit every other
night and have a conversation with
whoever the [ __ ] it was bill burr joe
rogan
[ __ ] uh any number of these guys that
were
their job was to talk and they got paid
millions of dollars to do it
and um
i thought because of that it [ __ ] me
up enough to where
i couldn't be at a party and listen to
some dude talk about his lawn
you know and i remember
my ex-girlfriend one of the reasons we
broke up
she said hey do you want to go to lunch
with me and my friend and i said
uh nah and she was like well why not and
i said
i don't know it's just your [ __ ] you go
and she was like well i would want to go
have
lunch with you and your friends and i
said [ __ ] no [ __ ] my friends
are will sasso and [ __ ] david off
you know and i was joking but i was
serious too
and i used that as an excuse to
compartmentalize like my [ __ ]
behavior
and um
i realize now that it wasn't
that it was i i didn't
feel good
just being just being i always felt like
there needed
to be some sort of safety or there
needed to be that high octane [ __ ]
mach 11 lifestyle
and through this past year of sobriety
i've just realized
i'm trying and it's a it's a work in
progress but
um and i hope this helps people but like
i'm
trying to be
i try to find that middle i want to get
to that middle and be
okay with that middle like i i was
talking to my therapist once and i think
i've talked about it on my podcast
before
about how you know um
i always felt like i had to do something
to make people like me when the truth is
i just like calvin because he's just
here you know and um
i don't know you don't have to do
something
you know what i'm saying you don't have
to walk into a room
and be something you can just be
and being comfortable
in that being is
is really hard for me and um
i don't know i hope what i'm saying is
is i i hope it i hope it helps people
and um you know all the shame
and the guilt and [ __ ] that uh that
comes with all of that
um if you if you feel it too because you
have your
uh demons or whatever the [ __ ] um
i uh i know it's a struggle so
you can do it and anyway i just figured
i should talk about that because it's
been a year
uh
i guess now we can
talk about [ __ ] uh
you know dumb [ __ ] like we do on this
podcast but uh
i i didn't even mean to start out like
that and i didn't even know if i was
gonna talk about it but i did and so
now we can talk about other things uh
like uh
[ __ ] buzzfeed articles and [ __ ] oh
actually you know what
i [ __ ] was uh reading this
article here oh wait let's talk about
this fight man
i watched the fight the floyd mayweather
fight with logan paul
um logan won before the fight it just
you win
man you did it you got there also that
dude
is like you know
it's it's so cool to watch him become a
man
because he was a kid you know we
people just expect so much of
[ __ ] you know this kid
filmed a video in in a forest and i know
this is old news now and nobody even
talks about it anymore and
and and and you know not even that we
should or we shouldn't but like
it it's it's so cool to see what he's
become and he's so obviously learned how
to grow up and be a man
and um you know after the fight when he
was just like man i hate being a dick
this is just cool to be here
and it was just cool to to see that um
and uh and it was wild he went eight
rounds with [ __ ] floyd mayweather i
mean
of course there was a size difference i
mean i'm sure if logan went up against
what's that guy dante dante wilder or
is it dante deonte i mean
whatever it is you know i'm it's like
i'm just a
white guy but like it's either dante
deontay or devonte
dude black people will just like add one
letter you know
like a name will get or be around for
like five years and i'll just be like
i'll let's add a v you know
and you're like krebs
yeah my uncle's name was craig i'm kraev
um you're like all right krebs because i
saw a [ __ ] guy
on was it the bachelor's name was his
name was
courtney and it was q-u-a-r-t-n-e-y
ah courtney you know that's like an
alien [ __ ] killed his parents and
then dressed up as his parents and were
like
let's name him courtney no one it's it's
regular name no one will know
and then they just uh oh on the birth
certificate
i don't know it sounds like quarter
q-u-a-r courtney
and uh so yeah so
anyway it was [ __ ] cool to see i
watched it with my parents and um
and uh you know my dad's always like who
so who is the it doesn't matter who the
[ __ ] if somebody's under 50 my dad's
like
who is that it doesn't matter it could
be like [ __ ] ryan gosling he's like
yeah
so i know and my dad's in the [ __ ]
business dude
and he's just like no i he was he was he
the one in and you're just like dad
you know who [ __ ] ryan phillippe is
you know yeah i think i i
and then sometimes yeah i know him
because i worked with him when he was
five like it was seth green
he's like i know he did a chips ahoy
commercial with him or some [ __ ] um
and so he's like so this guy's a boxer
now and i'm just like yeah and we did it
and the [ __ ] my mom was saying
during the fight just like oh oh
when when see oh he needs to punch him
more
like yeah no [ __ ] you know he's only
landing like 10 percent
imagine my mom as a boxing announcer oh
look at him
he's so much bigger
he's so much bigger why isn't there a
weight difference
there's a different club these are
different classes right this is my mom
during the this is the [ __ ] these are
the things that she was [ __ ] saying
oh we missed him like just [ __ ]
oh we missed him we're all watching oh
he's got no skills
that's what that's what she said
oh my favorite one was oh no don't do
below the belt
that's who you need to announce boxing
matches
because boxing is look let me just say
logan paul went [ __ ] eight rounds
with the greatest boxer alive
boxing is done do you know what i mean
floyd needed to knock that [ __ ]
out in two rounds
otherwise boxing is they're gonna offer
why the [ __ ] oh
i know he's a boxer now and he's a
talented athlete logan
but he's trying to shed his youtube
image it's like dude youtube
a youtuber went eight rounds with
[ __ ] floyd mayweather
that's it boxing is done turn on the ufc
do you understand what i'm saying
it's like [ __ ]
oh no don't do below the belt my mom
talks
to [ __ ] tv screens more than black
people
and that is that is that is two black
jokes and uh you know good thing i can't
be canceled again
but uh you ever watch a [ __ ] serious
i mean it's such a hacky joke but you
watch a horror movie with a black person
they're just like
don't go in there you're like no they
have to because it's part of the movie
and
uh anyway
i i i got this [ __ ] [ __ ] sometimes i
let me let me just play this this is you
can this is a
a lady who was spreading misinformation
on the um
uncovered on the uh that the covet
vaccines are
magnetized i just don't get how people
and some of the information that i think
had been discussed on your podcast this
is the other woman
ems frequencies podcast thoughts
because now because right now we're all
kind of hypothesizing i mean what is it
that's actually being transmitted
that's causing all of these things is it
a combination of the protein which now
we're finding has a metal attached to it
i'm sure you've seen the pictures all
over the internet
of people who've had these shots and now
they're magnetized
the key on their forehead it sticks i
stopped at the wrong time i'm so sorry
i'm deeply deeply
deeply sorry that i stopped at this
wrong [ __ ] time
because that's when it got good
hold on i gotta go back dude here we go
which now we're finding has a metal
attached to it i'm sure you've seen the
pictures all over the internet
of people who've had these shots and now
they're magnetized they put a key on
their forehead it sticks they can put
spoons and forks all over them and they
can stick
they can put spoons and forks all over
them cause they stick
whoa dude oh my god dude
get a [ __ ] different job whatever
your job is get a different job
dude get in a boat travel out there
jump off leave what are you doing
what are you doing what else does she
say
i think that there's a metal piece to
that there's been people who've long
suspected that there was some sort of an
interface first of all there's [ __ ]
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
people in the background
it's like a it looks like a judge judy
image you know what i mean like where
you see
she's she's again talking to i don't
know this is on the [ __ ]
literally on the ohio channel uncreative
um i mean dude try
ohio people make fun of ohio so much and
then they're just gonna have something
called
the ohio channel and there's [ __ ]
however many
people said and dude why are they not
all going
they're literally just sitting there
watching this lady talk about how
to be defined an interface between
what's being injected in these shots
and all of the 5g towers not proven yet
i'm so sick of people talking about 5g
that's being transmitted to these
unvaccinated people
that are causing health problems
i'm so so so sick of people saying 5g
i'm just so [ __ ] sick i i don't give
a [ __ ]
oh the government's tracking me after
the injection cool
good [ __ ] follow me everywhere the
government
follow me everywhere follow me to the
goddamn coffee bean
follow me to the deli follow me
[ __ ] driving around talking into my
phone making a tick tock follow me
government
it's just insane you got your phone in
your goddamn pocket
you have gps on you we're all robocop
anyway
drop them with the vaccines
drop them dude i don't understand
people are so that's the thing about the
[ __ ] internet dude
this is exactly what it is this is
exactly what it is
hear me out dude everybody has the
person
in your family that you either don't
invite to thanksgiving
or you dread inviting to thanksgiving
okay
and there's the other person in your
family that's like we gotta invite them
and you are all right fine we'll invite
them
you don't want to invite them and the
reason why you don't want to invite them
is because they've got like a weird job
and they're [ __ ] kind of bonkers
they'll say [ __ ] like well you know i
used to sell [ __ ] watches out of my
coat
or some [ __ ] and you're like really and
they're like yeah
or they say wacky [ __ ] [ __ ] that
just
doesn't gel with the family
the family's a unit and this guy's the
outlier
you know what i'm talking about
everybody's got that person
in their family all of those people
are now on the internet
everybody from that family is on the
internet
and they all found each other
all of these [ __ ] crazy lunatic
ass [ __ ]
found each other on goddamn twitter
they all signed into reddit and they're
like oh
you think biden's a lizard too hey wait
you think trump's actually dressed in
biden's skin
oh hold up you think nancy pelosi is a
hologram
cool what you doing for thanksgiving
you're not inv do these [ __ ]
out on the street
screaming about [ __ ] jesus christ
whatever the [ __ ] they're screaming
your government is this who's listening
there's a guy on hollywood and island
every day screaming he's got a little
[ __ ] karaoke box and a crate he
stands up
last night people are literally
saying get out of the way
that guy found ten thousand
other that guys on the internet
and it's working
they're in force they're mad because
they didn't get invited to thanksgiving
one year
so they created
lunacy they created
well you know the [ __ ] days coming
where they no no days coming
no day is coming it's today and
tomorrow's tomorrow
oh what happens if the thing doesn't
happen on the day and then the day well
the reason is because there was this was
the plan or
we just didn't know because they were
trying to tell us
but we didn't listen do your research
no do your research on how to become a
real person to get invited to [ __ ]
thanksgiving
do that research
5g their government is don't you think
it's [ __ ] odd
that uh bill gates and bill b [ __ ]
jeff bezos got divorced at the same time
they're gay lovers you know that right
they're gay lovers they're going to
marry each other and they're going to be
the richest guys in the world
and then they're going to inject us with
everything and we're all [ __ ] you know
that right
you know that right you know they're
going to [ __ ] and they're going to marry
not only themselves but their money
and then they can buy whatever they want
they could you know you know that right
you know we're gonna be enslaved right
you know freedom isn't free right
there's no freedom we're probably living
in a simulation right now
oh okay you know what fine even if you
are right
how the [ __ ] are you gonna stop it
bank manager what the [ __ ] are you gonna
do a plumber
oh really oh biden
is a lizard oh hillary clinton
ran pizzagate oh really
okay well
what are you gonna do a mailman
what are you what are you gonna do about
it
what are we gonna do about that that's
the whole thing to me man
the government's oh you know the
government's got secrets i
[ __ ] hope they do i don't want to
know everything
i'll be pissed the [ __ ] off dude i can't
even go get a goddamn
x-ray in my stomach last week without
getting pissed off at the lady working
the keyboard
you think i want to know what the
government is doing
well the government's not transparent
good
don't you think it's kind of weird no
no actually yeah that's all it is weird
it's so [ __ ] unreal dude
these people found each other we're
losing we're losing because they found
each other
the guy with [ __ ] gravy all over his
face
that's not wiping it
is running [ __ ] on reddit
you know what i'm saying
uncle greg is [ __ ] running [ __ ] on
on reddit he's running it and you're not
arguing online you're not even arguing
against it
do you know why because you've got a job
and a family
and you're level-headed so these
[ __ ]
are william wallace in their way to the
front line of
[ __ ] reddit
they can take our lives but they cannot
take our
parlor
you lunatics
and it's both sides dude it's both
[ __ ] sides
[ __ ] off with your oh well you're a
liberal oh will you no
dude i'm not either dude i'm chris
nice to meet you what do you believe in
ah [ __ ] i'll hear a few people talk
and then just be pissed off at all of
them
one time my friend was so drunk
at a party so [ __ ] drunk that he just
goes like this
and falls back purposely into a glass
table the glass table goes
[Music]
and he goes oh and i'm thinking what the
[ __ ] did you think was gonna happen
so i pick him up i bring him into his
bedroom
because the party was at his place and i
said hey man take off your shirt i want
to see if you're bleeding or not
and he takes off his shirt and he looks
at me
and he said what do you
breathe
and i said what and he said
what do you breathe and i said
air and he said
and that was
17 years ago
i've never been more confused in my life
until now with all the weird [ __ ] going
on
it's just every single [ __ ]
cock-sucking day dude
every single cock-sucking day
i go back to that time what do you
breathe
well the key magnetizes on your head and
there's obviously mag
oh it did someone shoot me with an arrow
yeah
why well why don't why do you think
oh no it's is it because i thought that
if you got the coven shot
blood from the mouth that you get mad
magnetized
and the key is and the king of sticks
your head
do you know they say if you get shot by
by a [ __ ] arrow you're supposed to
break it off and pull it out the other
way
nah if you shoot me with an arrow
bye bye i'll just die dude i'm not doing
all that work after
getting [ __ ] shot by an arrow what
you got
there's always there's some jackass at
the par well you know what you got if
you bring up
well you know you got to do if you get
shot by an hour you got to break it off
and pull it out the other way all right
what are you a [ __ ] marine
i'll just [ __ ] get i'll just die dude
that's it if you're lucky enough to
shoot me with a bow and arrow
i'm out i'm out i had a good life i had
a good life
i got my legacy calvin can grow up and
be like yeah my dad got hit with an
arrow and be a badass
wow everyone just dies a cancer your dad
got
shot by an arrow did he do the thing
where he broke nope my dad was too
stubborn
he said they got me and died
you ever think about all the people that
you met in your life
do you ever think about everybody that
you ever met in your life like how many
people that might be
and then sometimes people will pop in
your head like i'm at the age now where
i [ __ ] will remember somebody and
i'll be like
oh yeah that guy was a whole
person i knew for four years
i was just reminded i was on my youtube
and a video came up from a guy
that i used to [ __ ] hang out with at
the uh coffee bean
when i used to run that [ __ ] if
you go over the wee early episodes of
congratulations
i used to run that [ __ ] i used
to run that block dude
i was the mafia don of that i used to
talk about that in the early episodes of
congratulations that that coffee bean
doesn't exist anymore but there was a
sushi place
a [ __ ] salad place now there's like a
bank and a [ __ ] five guys
but dude i used to run that [ __ ]
man i knew everybody there
this guy used to come in i didn't really
know it then because i was like 24 but
he was just
he had a lot of men i guess he had
mental issues
but i [ __ ] loved that guy i loved
hanging with him um
really big dude and uh older you know i
don't know how old he is now but i found
out
he's still alive and doing [ __ ] and
still making these videos he used to
make these videos
and he would call us call the videos
gina and hello this is the gregory news
network
and uh i used to watch and i used to
i used to laugh with obviously like did
you just [ __ ] have your own channel
and
yeah i do and i make business cards and
he would make his own business cards and
hand them out would you like one and i'd
be like i should save those for other
people
okay just so you know you know and he
was one of those [ __ ] the
government you know yadda yadda
and he made this one song on youtube
that was go go go
obama go go go obama
but man he made this one song that i
think is beautiful it's so funny dude
let me play a little bit of it
former senior white house advisor how
did that come up how did that come up
three two one he does that thing like
it's just a youtube video he's like
three two
i gotta do that on congratulations
few years ago for my show
it's entitled here he made a song
i want to share with you now here's this
guy was a [ __ ]
always happy allah he's in florida now
but
eastern time which is 7 28 a.m
pacific time and now here's a song that
i wrote
a few years ago for my show
it's entitled and now this song is
dedicated
to all the beautiful ladies out there
that are single
and are christian so specific look and
here's the deal too
there isn't a more explains it all
that happens so quickly right here there
isn't a more
uh well that explains it then
what happens right here
i'm a christian okay it's called i love
beautiful women
this is a song that i wrote i love
every single day i love beautiful women
that's the only way and that's a portion
of the song that i wrote oh
give us a slice give us a slice
now that's a portion of the song that i
wrote i love beautiful women
that's the only way i love beautiful
women
each and every day now that's a portion
of the thought just gave us
a slice dude it's like when you know
someone's doing
the [ __ ] football halftime show and
they're rocking out but they only do
snippets of songs because i gotta fit
all the [ __ ] hits in this guy
gave us a slice
of moves of his moves like jagger
entitled i love beautiful women let me
sing
a portion of it again i love beautiful
women
every single day i love beautiful women
that's the only way what do you think
explains it all
in three two
uh i was married for almost 16 years in
los angeles
um my wife she left me in september
and explains it all immediately
2009 and divorced me in november of 2009
she's from the philippines
originally a mentor in los angeles on a
city
bus here's a picture of my wife tonight
i [ __ ] like this guy man i'm i i miss
seeing him actually because we
we used to [ __ ] just chill at the
coffee bean and then one time um
i drove by him and i was like i was like
james and he kept walking i'm like
james i hadn't seen him in years and he
kept walking i'm like james gregory
gregory news network and he turned and
he was like
oh hey how's it going and i was like hey
what's up dude
remember me and he was like yeah yeah
let me give you my card and um
and that was the last time i saw him and
now he's in [ __ ]
florida and i don't know why and but he
was in la for a while and and and uh
it's just
it's just crazy these people [ __ ]
come in and out of your lives
and i [ __ ] had so much fun with this
[ __ ] man
i don't know who knows if he'll [ __ ]
see this anymore i'll see this or not
but
i [ __ ] love people man i love people
i love their faces and [ __ ]
and just like the [ __ ] they say
and they're so [ __ ] annoying
sometimes
but it's just like that's them dude you
ever hear what's that saying if you knew
somebody's whole story you could never
hate them
whatever it is yeah
like this lady who thinks [ __ ] keys
can magnetize to your goddamn head
when she says it i'm like [ __ ] this lady
but like dude
who knows maybe your dad was like you
want a cookie
and she was like yeah and then he
[ __ ] goes like this
and ate it in front of her face and said
good night in the kitchen and locked her
in
um i want to do a buzzfeed
article because we did buzzfeed articles
one of these last times and it was
[ __ ] fun for me
guys are sharing man this one is guys
are sharing
men's secrets and they're surprisingly
really hilarious and wholesome
let me tell you something man no secret
is wholesome
okay
there's no no seek
a secret is something that you hear and
you go
what really
you know jimmy yeah you know
you know him and his wife they're
[ __ ] swingers every
friday night they go out to the parties
they got those masks on with the [ __ ]
nose dicks like eyes wide shut
and then we listen to that music
they do those parties we could just walk
by and just feel the girl's tits and
it's fine
jimmy and his [ __ ] wife do that what
they do
that's a secret
a secret is never wholesome
you're never like hey you know todd yeah
he likes rye bread
what
what do you mean like on his [ __ ]
sandwich like he'll put
he'll put turkey and cheese and all
[ __ ] mayonnaise and lettuce and
tomato
and a [ __ ] stacked rye bread a piece
of bread on the bottom and the top
really yeah him and his wife
him and his wife will be [ __ ] ripe
ripe sandwiches rye bread
the [ __ ] out of here jimmy jimmy this
one yeah
he seemed like such a [ __ ] regular
guy
so buzzfeed how guys are sharing men's
secrets
and they're surprisingly really
hilarious and wholesome
here we go last week i wrote a post
about guys sharing men's secrets well
our buzzfeed commenters came through
with some
additional examples of men's secrets and
they're also pretty entertaining to read
all right
here's what they said number one
losing your hair is extremely
distressing it makes you feel
unattractive old and insecure
not everyone has the face head to shave
off
remaining hair
get the [ __ ] out of here
seriously guys don't like to go
bald come on dude
you've got to be joking hey dude
you're going bald
hey man you're losing your hair i'm not
that's a [ __ ] crazy crazy secret did
you guys know that
i mean i know it's on buzzfeed and they
broke this news but i wanted to put it
on a platform also
to let you know that it's coming from
crystalia
guys don't want to go bald
here's another one adjusting the bits
oh i i don't like when just say
balls it's just like when somebody says
call women think it's funny oh the twins
are
talking about their boobs the twins are
just they're not twins they're all
twins twins are twins because some
people are twins if everyone's twins
they're not twins so you can't call your
boobs twins because they all look
similar if they're the both of them
always look similar
it makes sense if you [ __ ] think
about it and i'm not explaining it
further
adjusting the bits is second nature to
men and it isn't something we even do
consciously for the most part
true all it takes is accidentally
sitting on your balls once
and you will do anything to ensure it
doesn't happen again
okay sure so please don't overreact if a
guy adjusts his junk he probably needed
it and it probably didn't even and he
probably didn't even realize he was
doing it
i mean okay okay sure
you know secret no
sure though how about this one number
three i love cuddling next to my wife as
much as she loves doing it to me
it's the feeling of being wanted and
protected that is just amazing
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
dude hey sh
ah shut up you know
what the [ __ ] you like oh bro you like
codlin
this is not a secret who wrote this [ __ ]
tom cruise
i feel like tom cruise wrote this [ __ ]
tom cruise is like the kind of guy that
would be like
hey what's up guys yeah hey you know
what you know what you know what i like
doing
[ __ ] my wife and you're like all
right dude
isn't that crazy is that crazy sexy to
[ __ ] your wife
you're just like all right tom cruise
you're acting like you're
over are you gay what what kind of gay
guy loves [ __ ] his wife
i think it's extra sexy
look at this fourth one our balls are
sweaty almost all of the time
no they're not you [ __ ] weirdo
what do you what no they're not my balls
are drier than a [ __ ]
usually what are you doing all the time
that your balls are sweaty
that's disgusting bro
our balls are sweaty most of the time
that's like you know
like maybe a really hairy armenian dude
yeah bro i agree
you have to trim that though bro
otherwise your balls are sweating most
of the time i told that to buzzfeed bro
[Laughter]
our balls are sweaty most of the time
armenian dudes love the movie scarface
i'm like that you know that right
our balls are sweaty most of the time
and then also on top of that say hello
to my little friend my penis
hey for serious though first you get the
money then you get the power then then
comes respect
after that for limited time only you get
a free family mobile plan with
at the glendale galleria
limited time only bro oh [ __ ] one
time i was at a party and i saw a
[ __ ] armenian dude say
he like somebody was talking to him and
he like [ __ ] was showing him
something and he touched his face and he
was like
hey hey serious for serious though bro
don't touch my face man i don't like
that
i have a thing about my face and it was
so obvious that he didn't
he was just wanting wanted to be like a
guy with something ah
i love it dude that's like my friend's
[ __ ] wife once said
we should fix up an old car and then
guess if they did it or not um
here's number five women receive
compliments from men and other women
constantly but it's much more rare that
anyone will compliment a guy for
anything
they are some comp there are some
compliments that i received
years ago that i still think about to
this day
bro what what is happening to people
i want to be like what's happening to
men but it's not that it's everyone
what the [ __ ]
if you tell me a cop by the way this guy
don't
don't don't doesn't everyone get
compliments every day i'm not trying to
be like hey i'm the [ __ ] but like
th every few days somebody's at least
like hey
cool shoes or some [ __ ] they're like oh
your hair looks nice today
or maybe we can't do that now in the
[ __ ] woke environment
the last tv show i i i worked on they
they had like a [ __ ] um
uh an overview of everything you can and
can't do
and and and in the workplace environment
because you d about offending people and
[ __ ] and they basically just it was like
a [ __ ] 10 minute meeting and they
just showed up and they said
hey just [ __ ] keep your mouth shut
unless you're doing your lines
we're [ __ ] just shut the [ __ ] up don't
ever talk
she's like all right who doesn't get
compliments number one this guy's a
[ __ ] loser
second of all if you there are some
comments that i received years ago that
i still think about to this day like
imagine that guy doing that
imagine him just like
thinking about how somebody told him
that he's got [ __ ]
you know thighs that compliment his
[ __ ] torso too
number six funny one there are urinal
rules
when peeing oh this is i love rules okay
so i better like this one if no one is
there take a corner
if why why
if there is a urinal with a guy on the
right and nobody on the left remotely go
as far from said guy positive no way
[ __ ] no way dude uh uh
i go right next to the dude i use the
urinal right next to the dude
and i go like this we're a team now
and he goes and he says what and i say
we're a pissing team
what do you want to call ourselves
the falcons we're the falcons now
hope we win
that would be [ __ ] so dope
dude one time i was like [ __ ] 11 we
were at a dodger game or no i must
yeah well now we must have been at a met
game because i still lived in new jersey
and my dad loved the mets dude
and uh and i was in the
bathroom and i was waiting to pee
and the guy was peeing in front of me in
the urinal
and the guy said hey you want to back up
a little bit
could you get any closer and i was like
and i was like
what like
you can't do that you can't use like
sarcasm to like a nine-year-old you know
he was like hey hey if you was any
closer you'd be me
well i i know you i'm me i'm my own
person
you're a different person you have a
body and i have a body
and my dad was like hey why don't you
relax to the guy and i was like
i don't know what's going on right now
but if you fight there's gonna wind up
being pissed on all over all of us
we're gonna roll around and loss of piss
so don't find my daddy please
i will just step back a little bit and
then when you're done i will piss
and do tt's in where you did tt's you
don't even have to flourish
hey you just want to back up a little
bit
i no rules when you go into a men's bath
dude i start pissing as soon as i walk
through the door
i don't give a [ __ ] in my pants who
cares
i piss bro how baller would it be to go
in a men's bathroom and just go
and start pissing your pants great
you're wearing gray so it can be seen
you know
and everyone's like what are you doing
and i go like bro these urinals are for
[ __ ] i'm the man
oh [ __ ] i wanted i wanted and i want to
be
so famous so i can do that so there's
stories like that about how
wacky and insane i am it would be so
[ __ ] dope dude
and only wear sunglasses wow
imagine dude imagine a guy come on
come on with me on this journey [ __ ] npr
and listen to this
dude imagine going into a men's bathroom
at a [ __ ] dodger game with gray pants
on and sunglasses
and just walking two steps in and taking
a [ __ ] kibadachi stance
and just letting that [ __ ] tt
australia come out
i say with australia because when you
piss it looks always looks like
australia on your pants
and people say what the [ __ ] are you
doing and i go like this
urinals are for [ __ ]
i'm sorry little [ __ ]
i [ __ ] it up dude i hit snipes and hit
him up before i hit jeremy renner
and you go tt australia and people say
what are you doing
and i say urinals are for [ __ ]
[Music]
it's how it should have went and i
[ __ ] redid it and that's
a-okay wow
file's done
[Laughter]
bile's done bile's done
[ __ ] yeah dude wow can't believe i hit
[ __ ] snipes and tupac before i hit
that
renner
[ __ ] [ __ ] it you know
i love beautiful women each and every
day
i love beautiful women that's the only
way
dude i loved you know therapy is a form
of therapy but also this
podcast is a form of therapy
love doing it
[Music]
i don't know man what else what else can
we [ __ ] even
i'm sorry little kids that's it for this
episode on youtube
for the rest of the episode go and join
our patreon
uh it's raw and it's uncut uh
patreon.comcrystalia
and uh you can catch all the backlogs of
the other patreon epic you get a
an extra episode a month and uh
you can go watch them all right now over
the past months so sign up on our
patreon
uh for those and the rest of this
episode thanks oh dude and before we go
man
[ __ ] turn around and fart on that
subscribe button
just [ __ ] turn around and fart on
that subscribe button and as a matter of
fact
if you see somebody if you watch a video
where you see somebody say smash that
like button
smash that subscribe button do me a
favor
unsubscribe from that [ __ ]
i'm telling you right now turn around
and fart on that subscribe button dude
and then turn around another 360 and lay
another fart on that like button
and then bend down look square at that
bell notification and just
blow right on it dude fart fart bend
that's what i want you to do dude it
helps us
out on congratulations subscribe
[ __ ] fart subscribe fart like the
video
and then [ __ ] blow on that bell
notification
button appreciate y'all and
uh remember dude 40 pizzas in the last
30 days but also remember 40 pizzas in
the last 30 days
but also remember
okay dude thanks for listening
[Music]
thank you
no no no no angling it towards her but
but
twist it yeah okay well now it's too
much okay
no no more up up up up up up up okay
okay
the marijuana's got my vision clarity